bonjour bienvenue à tous nous sommes à
bruxelles au parlement européen pour
cette nouvelle édition d' europe hebdo
dans cette émission direction l'autriche
un pays où le taux de chômage des jeunes
est d'à peine 1%
un rêve pour la plupart de ses voisins
européens notamment au sud alors le
modèle autrichien d'apprentissage est il
transposable dans débattront avec nos
invités
mais d'abord l'actualité l'ump a voté à
désigner ses têtes de listes pour les
européennes
non sans polémique c'est la question de
la semaine enfin après des semaines de
tergiversations l'ump a voté les têtes
de liste aux européennes sont donc
désigné et après les accros de ces
derniers mois entre leaders du parti
c'est le temps de la paix des braves et
ses listes aux réserves comme d'habitude
quelques surprises
alain lamassoure ce parachute du sud-est
à l'ile-de-france pour laisser la part
belle à 1000 alliot marie
brice hortefeux rachida dati mais aussi
nadine morano
jérôme lavrilleux les bancs du parlement
européen risque fort de bruisser des
conversations d'état hors du mouvement
populaire d'anciens ministres ou des
proches des dirigeants qu'il faudrait
recaser après une défaite électorale en
somme
en attendant mieux alors le parlement
européen est il une salles d'attentes
pour des politiques en mal d'un parent
le parlement européen salles d'attentes
pour des politiques en mal de monde
c'est arnaud danjean qui va répondre à
cette question bonjour bonjour merci
d'être avec nous vous avez donc été
investis numéro deux sur la liste dans
l'est avec nadine morano en tête de
liste alors qu'est ce que vous pensez un
petit peu de ce casting de l'ump sur ses
têtes de liste on voit quand même
beaucoup de politiques à recaser en mal
de mandat le parlement est une chambre
de tente finalement non je ne pense pas
c'est toujours une polémique qui fleurit
au moment des désignations is to des
binômes pour chaque élection européenne
c'est le même refrain dans tous les
partis politiques d'ailleurs et il ya un
peu polémique
à mon avis excessive parce que quand on
regarde c'est un c'est un dosage entre
les gentils et et ceux qui sont
reconduits j'ai coutume de dire que moi
même il ya cinq ans j'étais entre ange
était nouveau donc je peux pas me
plaindre d'un système qui renouvelle
aussi les cadres donc voilà je crois
qu'on fait un peu de bruit ce qui est
vrai malgré tout c'est que la tension
qui est porté à la constitution de ses
listes
ça se fait toujours un peu une
extrémiste et c'est ce qui renforce ce
sentiment de malaise
je pense que le vrai problème de fond on
il est moins un moment de la désignation
des têtes de liste en dépit du bruit que
ça peut faire que sur la durée du mandat
je pense qu'il serait bon que les
appareils politiques les états majors
parisiens de tous nos appareils
politiques français se préoccupe un peu
plus quotidiennement pendant la durée du
mandat de ce qui se fait au parlement
européen vous par exemple durant votre
dernière mandature
vous vous êtes senti complètement
éloigné de l'état major parisien en gros
vous diriez que l'ump se fichant type ce
qui se passe à bruxelles au le pas
puisque l'ump que le ps donc donc
premier secrétaire siège pourtant en
tout cas essence et voilà mais donc tous
les partis politiques français ont le
même tropisme qui est un tropisme très
franco français alors ça peut justifier
à bien des égards mais c'est vrai que
quand on compare avec nos parlementaires
nationaux ont fait figure un peu de
parents pauvres dans l'intérêt qu'ils
nous qui est porté à nos travaux ça
c'est un petit peu améliorée pour être
très franc j'étais parlementaire
européen avant mais de ce que me disent
mes collègues qui sont là depuis
plusieurs mandats je trouve que lors de
la dernière mandature là quand même
eu des contacts un peu plus étoffé bon
ça reste quand même très en-deça qui se
passe pour beaucoup de nos collègues
européens d'autres nationalités en gros
il faudrait dire merci la crise
finalement qui a remis un peu l'europe
au centre au centre du jeu c'est vrai
j'ai vu leurs éléments il ya eu aussi le
fait que pour ce qui concerne mon parti
vous en parliez on a été aux
responsabilités donc dans cette période
de responsabilité exécutive en france il
ya eu un lien avec l'allemagne qui était
très fort qui a amené ici un certain
nombre de dispositions à prendre la
présidence mancelle égalise en france et
l'union européenne dont nous avons été
élus et moi même je mets mon élection le
conte très largement de la présidence
française de l'union européenne exercée
par nicolas sarkozy donc évidemment ça
renforçait quand même un peu le lien et
la dimension européenne
mais encore une fois ça restait très
insuffisant par rapport à ce que
connaissent d'autres pays alors pour
revenir justement sur ces listes le
problème qu'on voit maintenant c'est que
à force en fait devenir rocade et
d'anciens ministres en même temps damas
où des proches en fait des dirigeants on
voit jérôme lavrilleux qui est l'ancien
directeur de cabinet de jean françois
copé
il ya comme une perte d'influencé
prégnante de la france au sein des
commissions
quand on voit que l'allemagne en fait
reprendre un petit peu toujours les
mêmes les mêmes députés
sk pas un risque ici de voir l'influencé
française au sein des institutions
s'éroder ce qui existe indéniablement
mais je ferai pas de systématisation pas
par rapport aux entrants et au sortant
regardez
le cac qui me concerne moi j'étais entre
ans la dernière fois donc j'étais tout à
fait novice et pour autant j'ai décroché
une présidence de commission que
j'estime exercer honorablement qui est
un vecteur d'influencé pour pour mon
parti pour la france plus généralement
tout en étant encore une fois un primo
entrants
donc je ne ferai pas de 7,6 du cas par
cas
ça dépendra vraiment de l'implication
que chacun y met je moi je ferai pas de
procès d'intention à telle ou telle paix
parce qu'il met parce qu'il est ancien
ministre ou parce qu'ils les cadres du
parti tels que quand nadine morano dit
qu'elle a l'intention de ses jets de
manière durable au parlement européen
vous le croyez j'ai pas le procès
d'intention à faire encore une fois tout
est n'avait aussi des députés sortants
qui vont peut-être être en roue libre et
10 rebonds bah moi je t'ai déjà été élu
j'ai déjà fait un mandat c'est plus
tranquille
voyez donc je ferai pas de procès
d'intention c'est du cas par cas ça
dépendra de l'implication un ancien
ministre peut avoir un impact ici il ya
beaucoup d'anciens ministres voire
d'anciens présidents d'autres pays qui
ici et on leur fait pas le reproche
d'être dans une salle d'attenté dans une
salle de recadrage
donc voilà il ya des coups de
projecteurs qui ont été mis et c'est
naturel au moment de cette compétition
interne je crois malgré tout que encore
une fois le le procès d'intention et
parfois un peu un peu excessif alors il
ya eu un autre procès d'intention je
souhaiterais qu'on écoute en rigolant
rigonnaud pardon qui est député ump des
yvelines qui a semble-t-il quelques
soucis avec la tête de liste qui a été
investi par l'ump on écoute
unique la tête de liste en ile-de-france
imprime sa marque très profondément sur
la ligne défendue par l'ump on a il a
été décidé qu'elles sont confié alain
lamassoure
il incarne une certaine idée europe et
aux fédéralistes plutôt dans la ligne de
ce qui se construit depuis une trentaine
d'années
moi je partis de tous ceux qui à l'ump
et parmi les français regardent cette
construction d'un regard critique
aujourd'hui voilà qu'on décide de parité
en tête de liste quelqu'un qui incarne
qui est qui
des études niveau complètement linden
ump alors c'est la question que tout le
monde se posait alors du conseil
national quelle est la ligne sur
l'europe de l'ump
la ligne de l'ump elle a été rappelée
d'ailleurs façon tout à fait éloquente
est clair par jean françois copé qui a
commencé son discours en disant ce qui
est la vérité ce qui est la vérité
depuis très longtemps ce qui est
génétique à l'ump
l'ump est un parti européen oui enfin
dider qu' il n'a rien on suit cette
europe là il ya des choses il ya des
choses à revoir on est tous conscients
qu'il ya des choses à ajuster mais c'est
de l'ordre
justement c'est pas de l'ordre là
j'entends de la déconstruction l'a
d'abord la déconstruction c'est pas au
parlement européen qu'elle se fait
savoir pourquoi on élit les députés
européens les députés européens ils sont
là pour peser sur l'orientation des
législations européennes
ils sont pas là pour déconstruire
l'europe où la houle à reconstruire
alors les ça ça va être au moment des
présidents ans oui mais là c'est trop
bien que l'orientation fédéral ou moins
fédéral où tout ce qu'on veut et ses
mots m'agace prodigieusement parce que
ça correspond pas aux réalités
mais si on veut peser sur l'orientation
de la construction européenne
le parlement est une des modestes pierre
de cet édifice
mais le vrai pouvoir il reste aux
exécutifs nationaux donc leurs favoris
en occasions c'est à ce moment là qu'ils
se montrent des présidentielles en
france qu'on pèse vraiment sur
l'orientation de la construction la home
niveau des élections européennes ce sur
quoi on paie c'est sur l'orientation des
législations européennes ne faut pas
tout confondre
il faut pas que ce débat européen pour
les élections parlementaires devienne un
débat fourre tout où chacun arrive avec
ses frustrations par rapport à l'europe
d'être construit aujourd'hui
des voix qui font entendre mais moi je
refuse ce discours qui consiste à dire
les élections européennes sont décisives
pour savoir si on déconstruit l'europe
ou si on a reconstruit une ode mais
quand vous voyez les derniers sondages
qui indiquent que marine le pen front
national vont être le premier parti sur
ces européennes
est-ce que là on n'est pas dans cette
éternelle clivages de l'ump qui courent
un petit peu derrière le fn parce que on
est dans cette espèce de ligne je dis à
mes amis confrères mes collègues
militants de l'ump jeudi vous trompez
pas vous trompez pas d'enjeu encore une
fois sur des élections européennes on va
voter pour élire les représentants
français qui vont venir siéger dans une
assemblée où il ya 751 enfin il y en
aura sept cents un peu plus de 750
membres
est ce que vous croyez que 20 membres de
l'ump vont construire l'europe où la
reconstruire dans une assemblée de 760
personnes
évidemment non c'est pas ça le sujet
premièrement deuxièmement on peut être
profondément européen et patriote
moi j'attends qu'on vient de me faire
des procès en patriotisme j'ai travaillé
pendant dix ans au ministère de la
défense français quelle institution
souveraine par excellence au niveau
national je préside une commission de
sécurité défense j'ai un attachement
profond viscéral à ma nation je suis pas
pour autant anti européen donc ces
débats sont un peu stérile c'est des
débats très franco-français en plus qui
se pose beaucoup moins dans les autres
pays un petit peu en angleterre mais on
a eu le caron guay mais l'avait fait
avant qu'on frappe 9e mais aussi mais
moi ce que je voudrais dire c'est
regarder ce qui se passe chez nos
confrères allemands l'accès dès août ses
sous c'est un parti évidemment
profondément européen et qui va faire le
procès à ses députés allemands ou même
merkel de ne pas être une patriote
allemande donc cessons ces débats
théologiques je veux bien qu'on
réfléchisse forme que doit prendre
l'europe à l'orientation qu'on doit lui
donner
erquy foi croire qu'on va pouvoir
déconstruire les choses en reconstruire
d'autres sur des sur des grandes
rhétorique le fédéralisme le
confédéralisme l'europe des nations
l'europe des peuples tout ça permettez
moi de vous dire c'est la fadaise par
rapport au travail qui est à faire ici
eh bien écoutez merci à madame c'est là
dessus que va se terminer notre moment
nous on compte chaque partie magazine de
cette émission avant de rejoindre nos
invités direction l'autriche
il y a quelques semaines jean marc
ayrault il a été faire une petite visite
pour voir comment l'apprentissage pour
les jeunes s'effectuer finalement et bah
c'est plutôt de bon élève
puisque moins de neuf pour cent d'entre
eux sont au chômage est un reportage dé
paul bouffard
ces petits bonhommes en bleu sur le
symbole d'une réussite
intel à l'autrichienne où l'apprenti les
rois jean marc ayrault est venu chercher
des solutions au problème du chômage des
jeunes en france
si le taux de des moins de 25 ans est un
des plus bas de l'union européenne
8,7 pour cent seulement il est encore
tôt qu'en radovan enfile son bleu de
travail dans la banlieue de vienne la
capitale autrichienne
c'est le début des cours au centre
d'apprentissage jugend hommes verts qu
entendez la jeunesse au travail
le jeune homme s'équipent et sous l'oeil
de son formateur il s'exerce à la suze
loto de ce cantonnement le consolider et
le dur est ok ok tu sais tu raques cette
machine c'est bon pour toi ok comme
radovan 40% des jeunes autrichiens vont
vers l'apprentissage
depuis 2008 chaque jeune qui terminent
l'école obligatoire à l'âge de 4 ans est
en droit de recevoir une formation quand
ils ne la trouve pas seuls l'état
autrichien l'orientent le suit et le
format un métier radovan lui veut
devenir sidérurgiste vous a fait le
ménage pages prend vraiment plus de
plaisir à travailler ici plutôt que
d'être simplement ainsi à l'école
j'étais très confiant sur le fait
trouver un emploi le secteur de la
métallurgie est très demandée surtout
quand on a reçu une bonne formation
on est presque sûr de trouver un travail
en sortant d'ici son ca ici on
s'organise en atelier autonome - de casa
apprentis par classe la journée débute à
7h15 elle s'achève à 16h15
c'est presque la même chose qu'on
entreprises ici sauf que là nos profs
prennent vraiment en bien nous expliquer
ce qu'on va faire perdre
c'est pour ça que ça me plaît l'autriche
le royaume de l'apprentissage
comme son voisin allemand il fait figure
de modèle c'est depuis ce bureau du
emploi autrichien que le système est
piloté on peut voir juste au milieu de
l'écran le chiffre du chômage dans le
pays juste au dessus là vous voyez on
peut lire le chiffre de près de 3000
nouveaux chômeurs aujourd'hui avec ses
écrans johannes coop est à la tête de la
ms le pôle emploi autrichien quand
certains voient des effets pervers du à
l'orientation trop précoce dès 15 ans
lui se voit la raison de la réussite ce
grand artiste
il ya d'abord ce test c'est important de
savoir ce qui intéresse les jeunes la
première question que tu fais est déjà
mauvaise
la réponse est souvent rien la question
doit être est ce que ça t'intéresse
c'est aussi ce que veulent les
entreprises les entreprises veulent des
gens en tout ce test un communiqué saab
est une sonnette avec un goût de
community e mails et cyrill touré trois
années d'apprentissage avec à la clé un
certificat est une réussite garantie
près de 90% des jeunes trouvent un
emploi
les entreprises sont friandes de ces
jeunes qualifiés ben là je vais faire un
poinçon pour que mon collègue puisse
leur travail et ensuite il va couper
cette pièce là ça va être gros nez les
et ensuite je vais utiliser la machine à
baffes et pendant sa formation
que je nomme et même payer 300 euros par
mois la première année 700 euros pendant
la dernière pour moi samba ça me
convient ici j'apprends je ne suis pas
là pour l'argent
j'acquiers des compétences pour plus
tard c'est surtout pour ça que je suis
ici depuis 2006 par tina ly poots et à
la tête de ce centre de formation
intermédié a compris c'est très clair
250 apprentis et un objectif pédagogique
que ces jeunes évoluent vers l'autonomie
professionnelle mais aussi social départ
en sprint il ya toujours des jeunes qui
arrivent ici pour lesquelles on se dit
prêt n'ont pas confiance en eux
mais on voit leur évolution après un ou
deux ans il échange ils osent ils se
réjouissent même quand ils réussissent
un stage avec un retour positif de
l'entreprise ils comprennent qu'ils sont
capables quand on les re devenir adulte
et avoir une évolution si positive se
prendre en main c'est gagné il y avait
au total une soixantaine de centres
d'apprentissage dans tout le pays
l'autriche consacre l'un des plus gros
budget de l'union européenne et pour
l'état c'est un gros investissement 130
millions d'euros pour faire fonctionner
le programme young hee nam werk le
ministre du travail est lui même un
ancien apprenti employeurs et employés
ont travaillé ensemble pour créer ce
système de formation et il continue à le
développer constamment
ça a toujours été entre prioritaires
l'autriche de donner du travail
aujourd'hui même en cette période de
crise plutôt que de payer des
allocations chômage nous préférons
investir de l'argent pour qualifier les
gens en classe tu radovan et ses
camarades suit aussi des cours
théoriques compris dans la formation
aujourd'hui son avenir est tout tracé
enfin une froide
oui bien sûr j'aimerais que mes enfants
passaient même chose j'ai accumulé de
bonnes expériences ici et ce n'est pas
fini je trouve l'apprentissage très
important car ensuite les portes sont
toujours ouvertes si on veut faire un
autre métier
ici on n'y arrive pas on peut toujours
se réorienter dans le secteur de sa
formation
les entreprises doivent parler des
employés qualifiés
c'est très important qu'on ne sait pas
exactement où on va travailler plus tard
lutter à tout prix contre ce chômage des
jeunes en autriche un objectif zéro
chômeur
en 2016 pour les jeunes déscolarisés la
formation deviendra obligatoire et les
sanctions seront lourdes jusqu'à des
amendes pour les parents
l'exemple donc autrichien est il un
modèle à suivre pour débat de ses
questions je reçois deux députés bonjour
mesdames donc bah vous êtes députée
allemande
bernadette vergnaud vous êtes française
et vous avez toutes les deux travaillé
sur cette question alors je me tourne
vers vous madame la maire est-ce que
c'est un exemple à suivre
après tout on a l'impression un petit
peu de réinventer l'eau chaude non c'est
un exemple à suivre mais je crois qu'il
faut l'adapter à chaque pays en europe
chaque pays est différent
il a eu une histoire et une culture
différente mais je crois qu'en france
nous avons vraiment perdu beaucoup de
temps il est indispensable d'avoir un
socle intellectuelle un socle qu on se
cultive
intellectuellement on apprend les
savoirs indispensables et en même temps
par exemple un jeu qui sont sûrs d'une
classe quand on voit qu'il n'a pas envie
d'apprendre il faut que relativement
jeune on puisse développer toutes ses
capacités de création d'innovation et de
rêves d'avenir et certains ça passe par
l'artisan par profession j'allais dire
qu'ils sont à l'heure actuelle
sous-estimé dont l'enseignement en
france on n'a jamais été capables de
faire travailler vraiment de façon très
serrée l'éducation nationale et les
artisans et les grandes entreprises
et je crois que là on a pris beaucoup de
recul même si on commence maintenant
puisque c'est la crise à avancer dans
ces domaines là mais c'est indispensable
et un jeune a 16 ans si par exemple il
apprend à créer chez un artisan
l'artisan l'artisan s'éduque la création
mais c'est aussi de l'art parfois et je
crois que si on n'est pas dévaloriser
tout ça dans la tête des jeunes dans la
tête des familles
eh bien je crois que là on le monte on
pourrait être comme autriche comme la
finlande comme l'allemand ou comme
pleinement justement cet exemple
tricheurs c'est un petit peu aussi comme
ça que ça fonctionne en allemagne
comment est-ce qu'on pourrait finalement
transposer ça d'autres pays européens
notamment donc la france ou les pays du
sud qui connaissent je pense notamment à
l'italie 40 % de chômage chez les moins
de 25 ans je dirais que le système ait
un très bon système pour l'allemagne
parce que nous avons une culture une
tradition dans ce domaine là c'est une
tradition aussi il faut dire où les
entreprises sont doivent être aux normes
sont parties prenantes et s'ils ne le
sont pas alors c'est très difficile à
faire
donc il faut réellement a juste
et dans les états membres la manière
dont ça peut être fait mais je pense que
la plus qu'il ya dans ce système c'est
que les jeunes ont cette éducation à
l'école et l'éducation en entreprise
c'est à dire commence déjà à apprendre
comment ça fonctionne dans une
entreprise à faire valoir ce qu'ils ont
appris avec leurs propres mains parce
que pas tous les jeunes sont des
intellectuels et je pense que dans ces
métiers
c'est une direction des métiers très
fort en fait est une grande grande force
de l'allemagne justement c'est d'avoir
une productivité très poussées main
d'oeuvre qui est très capable et c'est à
cela qu'il faut le voir c'est un peu le
modèle allemand aussi à ce niveau-là
koala à ce niveau là oui c'est une des
bases c'est une des bases les jeunes qui
savent faire et qu'ils ont ça dans la
tête et dans les mains et je pense que
ça c'est des grands avantages
justement vous parliez de dévalorisation
en fait de ce modèle
d'artisans et de métier ul la classe
d'âge 80 % doutais d'âge au bac c'est un
peu ce qui a tué l'artisanat et les
filières manuel française alors on
revient finalement 40 ans en arrière qua
non mais je crois que c'était une bonne
idée et 4 parce qu on a besoin aussi
chaque citoyen a besoin dans sa vie
d'être responsable et pourrait être
responsable
il faut avoir une base solide comme le
disait maintenant des bars d'une base
solide et intellectuelles et en même
temps les savoirs fondamentaux
je crois que c'est indispensable par
exemple qu'un jeune puisse être capable
de se faire une demande d'emploi sans
faire de fautes d'orthographe s'en
foutent de deux français ou d'allemand
enfin mais c'est indispensable certes
mais en même temps ne pas occulter toute
la capacité personnelle de création dans
chaque individu et il y à des individus
et ça se détecte très jeune au collège
on le voit bien qu'ils ont envie d'être
technicité automobile ou ou artisan
menuisier et on a tué ça parce qu'on n'a
pas comme le disait madame débarque
justement eu en france par exemple une
culture d'entreprise à l'école et
d'écoles dans l'entreprise
et ça je crois qu'on en avril réinvente
on réinvente parce que c'est si
fondamentales et la directive sur les
qualifications professionnelles lesquels
on a travaillé ensemble que j'étais
rapporteur mais évelyne les
coordinateurs dans notre groupe
je crois que c'est la dimension
européenne qu'on a voulu donner c'est
vrai que c'est bon si on veut sortir de
la crise et si on veut que les jeunes
avancée les moins jeunes d'ailleurs il
faut aussi leur donner de la mobilité
professionnelle mais la sécuriser et
sécuriser leur parcours professionnel
alors justement
lors d'un sommet européen qui a été donc
derrière suivie d'une visite dans la
merkel à françois hollande pour cette
question du chômage des jeunes il y a eu
l annonce en fait d'une espèce de
garantie jeunesse avec une enveloppe de
42 milliard sur sept ans pour 6 millions
jeunes alors on va pas ici faire des
additions
non mais c'est quand même une petite
goutte d'eau que ce genre de situation
oui disons il faut faire quelque chose
c'est bien clair mais je pense que les
avancées que les états membres ont fait
sur les avants c'est quand même très
timide très très très timide et je pense
qu'il faut faire beaucoup plus et quand
la commission européenne dit nous devons
faire quelque chose pour les jeunes et
de dire mais c'est aux états membres de
le faire je dis je c'est malheureux
c'est malheureux nous devrions en faire
beaucoup plus européen a d'autant que la
plupart des pays confrontés à spa sont
des pays en crise on pense à l'invasion
face à l'espagne on pense à la glace
nous voilà à l'heure à sécher voilà et
la politique est faite en ce moment dans
l'union européenne justement pour les
paye dans le sud
c'est une mauvaise politique parce que
c'est la politique qui crée le chômage
des jeunes en fait incroyable donc ne
devons pas seulement donner de l'argent
pour l'éducation
nous devons faire aussi en sorte que les
règles que nous avons dans nos états
membres soit plus sociale et plus juste
pour les jeunes surtout et qu'ils aient
aussi une personne est il dans leur vie
et donc je pense qu'il ya beaucoup de
choses à mettre à plat et pas seulement
un beau projet qui est un petit
commencement trop timide et mais il faut
en faire beaucoup plus et 42 milliards
c'est une opération de communication
c'était juste de l'annoncer dans pas
seulement je crois qu'il faut enclencher
le processus mais il faut aussi qu'il y
ait enfin un souffle européen un esprit
européen la crise était alors ça c'est
du rsa aussi qu'on veut c'est des voeux
pieux mais bon il faut absolument qu'on
n'essaie concrètement de créer cette
marché du travail européen où il peut y
avoir des opportunités que chacun puisse
saisir à un moment donné dans sa vie et
nous c'est ce qu'on a fait mais aucun
niveau du parlement on est beaucoup plus
de l'avant ça là dessus par rapport aux
états par rapport à la gestion j'ai
parlé
cadre commun de formation
professionnelle et à la fois d'un
intellectuel dans les universités grâce
à sa déjà commencé mais quand j'ai posé
la question au conseil et madame gebhart
on était petits mois ça a été un non on
n'y arrivera pas et bien on y arrive et
on a longtemps pour cette carte
professionnelle européenne genre 2004 on
va les obliger à oui on y arrive tout de
même à force de vraiment convaincre et
non quand c'est possible à ce qu'il faut
diriger mais c'est possible au niveau du
parlement ya une volonté effectivement
d'agir sur cette question il ya une
envie d'une europe plus sociale qui
protège en fait notamment les jeunes qui
en ont le plus besoin c'est quoi c'est
le conseil c'est les gouvernements
nationaux qui bloque qui finalement sont
là dans une stratégie
ce sont les gouvernements nationaux qui
regarde de trop près leur propre
situation et ne pensent pas d'une
manière globale d'une manière européenne
de manière à faire des plus values
commune on a toujours l'impression quand
on voit les conseils européens quand ils
sortent quand nos chefs d'état madame
merkel et les autres sont allés gagner à
ils ont tous gagné et surtout ils ont
fait quelque chose contre les autres et
contre l'europe et c'est dommage c'est
dommage
au lieu de chercher la plus value
européenne au lieu de faire que la carte
professionnelle que nous avons enfin pu
mettre en rouge mais seulement sur une
base volontaire
nous nous l'a voulu et voulait en avoir
les droits et iv xavier temps là mais
les états membres n'étaient pas prêts
pour revenir sur cette question de
l'apprentissage
comment est-ce qu'on pourrait mettre en
place un système qui puisse fonctionner
au sein de tous les états européens
n'existent pas de pôle emploi à l'europe
n'existe pas de système d'éducation
nationale et un est-ce qu'il ya quelque
chose en fait à pouvoir poser sur ces
questions là déjà je pense que pour
rebondir sur ce qu'a dit evelyne
gebhardt quand on parle d'éducation au
niveau des états c'est nationale
respecte nationale quand on parle de
l'angoissé l'angoissé quand on parle de
l'emploi les affaires sociales
c'est nationale on voit bien qu'en
période de crise il faut qu'on se
fédèrent à la fois nos systèmes de
formation et nos systèmes sociaux
donc à partir de là il faut trouver
quelle est la bonne harmonisation qu'on
peut construire et à un moment donné
pour qu'on pense automatiquement plus
values européenne et non pas seulement
socle national et ça on a beaucoup de
difficultés et quand on a voulu par
exemple que les stages dans cette
directive les stages soient des contrats
qu'ils soient sécurisés reconnu après la
mobilité fonctionnelle c'est énorme moi
je suis en espagne plusieurs fois faire
des colloques
quand on dit ça aux jeunes pagnol qui
sont en chômage par exemple plus de 50%
en andalousie autant leur dit qu'ils
pourront bénéficier d'un stage qui sera
reconnue c'est un contrat ça sera pas
bidon qui a apprise auront aussi une
carte professionnelle qui leur permettra
d'avoir un cursus marqué tout au long de
leur vie
tout ce qu'ils feront même si ça dure
six mois un an
on sent une vague d'espoir at il faut
que ce n'est pas lui manquer politique
résonne aussi comme eux et comme nous et
ça on a du mal parce que en plus values
européenne mais on parle pas vraiment
fédération coopération un dernier mot
rapide manebard justement sur cette plus
value européenne mais sur cette volonté
d'uniformiser est ce que vous y croyez
encore oui j'y crois je ne crois pas à
l'uniformisation parce que yelle et les
traditions les cultures sont trop
différentes
mais à lire des romans des plus values
une plus grande ouverture entre les
états membres justement dans le domaine
de la culture de l'éducation de la
formation professionnelle serait
vraiment la bienvenue
écoutez merci mesdames d'avoir été avec
nous pour évoquer cette question nous
c'est la fin de cette émission vous avez
rendez vous la semaine prochaine avec
ahmed tazir bonne semaine sur les
chaînes parlementaires
liberté égalité